ce serait installé ici sur les
promontoires pour chasser le potentiel
menkari bout en bout des archéologues
croit avoir trouvé le premier site
d'embuscades de chasse au caribou au
nouveau brunswick jaune à l'époque et
encore le caribou
sinon j'en vis sans fin sans regarder le
comportement assez complaisants suivent
toujours les mêmes routes
donc s'il fallait ici qu'à tous les qui
va vers les lacs les gens qui la bbc de
savoir que tous les gens qu'il attendait
de l'attendre pour pouvoir rechercher la
hauteur des campements aurait permis aux
chasseurs de piéger l'animal depuis
plusieurs semaines une équipe
d'archéologues et de techniciens des
terres des milliers d'artefacts datant
de plus de 3000 ans mais qu'en réponse à
la fédé unités la remettre à m donc tout
est diffusé ici sens nord sud est ouest
on a deux ondes d'escalation d'après
vous ce qu'on avait tous les artefacts à
la base qu'on a fait le sondage
on a plusieurs points de l'entraînement
on a deux fragments dit phase 6 ou 7 mm
et le pointe mais ils pressent sur la
foi des couteaux ou c'est juste
les ébauches pour faire des points 2 2
l'an on a quatre fois les anciens foot
15 comme le charbon
on a un labo on a désormais entre ses
mains des analyses des ossements et des
résidus de protéines sur les artefacts
permettront de valider qu'on y chassait
berry bien le caribou cas des gens ils
ont des champions sol leur père à 15 min
sik pour vraiment numéro le catalogue
comme sont aussi de la provenance exacte
des objets à chaque semaine dans les
amènent leurs bureaux d'archéologie et
on y va on va les analyser et on va les
rapports de pouvoir
si facile a fait savoir que les gens à
mieux comprendre comment les gens qui
parlent territoire l'époque ça toujours
été ce qui fascine et man en fait dans
l'archéologie comprend les relations
entre l'homme et la nature
ces découvertes pourront aussi servir de
modèle d'identification afin d'éviter la
construction de routes sur des sites
similaires
les fouilles devraient être complétés
d'ici deux à trois semaines ici camille
bourdeau radio-canada ça sexe